have the B-R-A-F-B-600-E mutation does the cell pathway, but this mutation
functions similar to the k-ross and the m-tore in terms of what specifically stimulates
the cancer cell growth. Here's your great video, link and graphic on slide two. So I looked up because
I wanted to know what graphic this person was talking about. This is a video that I created.
This, I'm pretty sure this is the graphic they were talking about. So this is a graphic
talking about the m-tore pathway. M-tore is a growth pathway and there's all these things in yellow,
EMF cell towers, high fructose quartz syrup, fructose high sugar,
ironed rich foods and then where applicable the gene expression that will make, you know, give
iron a greater chance of stimulating growth. With sugar here, you could probably add the H-I-F-1-A-G-D
here, which would cause, you know, more glucose to stimulate the m-tore pathway to stimulate growth.
All these things we've talked about over the years, you know, that can stimulate growth and the
stimulate the m-tore pathway is just one reason why some of these will stimulate growth. The
metal supplement, supplementation we've talked about that, it actually stimulates the m-tore pathway
but it also blocks, turns off to the spresser genes. Pesticides stimulate, glutamate,
stimulate the m-tore pathway, etc. So the question was, is the B-wrap gene mutation the same as
or similar to the m-tore pathway? And I'd say the answer to be yes and no. The B-wrap pathway is
considered a tumor oncogene which having that mutation actually stimulates a cell to go into
rapid replication, whereas stimulating m-tore through anything here
doesn't stimulate a cell to go in to become a cancer cell but it would stimulate a cancer cell
to continue to replicate. So yes and no, kind of. I would say that the answer to that would be yes,
kind of. It kind of is similar to the m-tore pathway. The K-ros pathway is another pathway,
it's very similar to that. K-ros pathway is different in the sense that K-ros is considered a tumor
suppressor gene and defects on that gene cause block, defects on that gene,
limit intrinsic pathway through the K-ros pathway, K-ros gene, intrinsic pathway
tumor cell death. So it inhibits tumor cell death, that's the K-ros pathway. So if you have defects
on the K-ros pathway, you have inhibition of tumor cell death, whereas if you have defects of the
B-wrap pathway, you have stimulation of tumor cell growth. Kind of the same thing, but not really.
End point is the same thing, the cancer continues to proliferate, but a little bit different mechanism.